corey kluber with the indians he wanted
cy young and 14 he won a cy young in 17.
forget last year he was hurt
and he's also third all time on indian
strikeout list bob feller of course
number one there but three is not a bad
number for corey kluber in cleveland
indians history the guy like corey
kluber you don't often think in terms of
him needing a lot of help but today
he'll take it no doubt if he can get it
excited to see him in those powder blues
rocky's lineup david dahl leading things
off again story and blackman to follow
strike three called right on the inside
corner and dahl
down looking
one of the many things to do about corey
cooper is his ability to hit his spots
and you see that entire at-bat all seven
pitches is a beautiful pitch from corey
cooper who just records his first
strikeout as a member of the rangers
blackman big numbers last season all for
eight in this series kluber's 2-1 pitch
to black
in the air
shallow right no doors out there
and that's the inning
kyle freeland on the hill for the
rockies as bud black said
maybe
more anxious than anybody on the roster
to get into this 2020 season
in the air to center field david dahl's
out there even in the first five pitches
you saw from 92 to 82. the breaking ball
he threw was at 82. well not a whole lot
going on in that first inning i say
looking at the scoreboard and yet we are
stunned
at a development here as we come back
for the second inning and corey kluber
did not come out to pitch instead joe
palumbo will get as much time as he
needs well we just got the news on
kluber he left the game with tightness
in his right shoulder
joey gallo to lead things off in the
second freeland's 1-0 and that ball hit
high very deep out to right gone
and there you see it the first massive
home run of the year for joey gallo
rangers on top one nothing
this ballpark can't hold joey gallo
especially when he catches a pitch out
front the way that he just did right
there and that strong follow-through
that we get from the big left-hander a
double a bunt single and they're on the
corners for solac
and this one through the right side base
hit
ref schneider's in andrews will stop at
second but solak picks up the rbi to
make it two nothing
all at first nobody out two-and-oh on
story
and trevor hits it in the air to gallow
deep right field did he get it you bet
to a game-tying homer
trevor story and the rockies have their
first home run of 2020
and story in the fourth ties it up but
the way this has been playing there's
been a few balls of the hit you think oh
that has a chance to get out so you have
to wait a moment to watch joey gallo go
back on that ball it's a bases loaded
nobody out situation ryan mcmahon at the
plate
one two
in the air to center field plenty deep
enough
blackman will tag at third the throw
will go towards third to hold nolan from
moving up and nolan gets back safely and
now they have murphy hung up for a
moment and he
army crawls back into first it's always
a mini drama
sometimes
back to the top of the order elvis
andrews one and two there's a ground
ball past the mound story at short has
it spins throws and he gets him
tremendous play by trevor story whose
follow through carries him all the way
out into right center field that is a
dandy play by the shortstop from irving
it'll be trevor story leading it off
trev with a two-run homer last time up
the first homer of the year for the
rockies that tied the game before the
rockies took the lead with three runs in
that fourth inning
and that one is long gone take a good
look you won't see it for long
second dick shot here in texas and it's
four to two colorado the first one
you're waiting did he get it enough was
it going to be far enough
this one no doubter that would have been
out of irving high school
he maybe hit it to irving
2-1 tony swings drives it towards right
gallow has to play on the bounce
rounding third owings heading to the
plate to throw the slide not in time
tony walters with an rbi single and the
rocky's lead grows to five to two there
is a shot that they get this i thought
this was a long shot just because it's
late in the game but absolutely not it's
a really good challenge here for the
rangers
and they said he's safe
here's the 3-2
on the ground to nolan good place to hit
it you want the game over and the
rockies behind a one two three ninth
from wade davis he earns his second save
the rockies have earned their second
victory of the year
trevor story a pair of home runs in his
homecoming and the rockies take two of
three on the road in texas